من جديد وفي وقت ترتفع فيه الاسعار للسلع
الغذائيه يعود الواجهه مرض جنون البقر
مثيرا القلق في عده دول خلال ايام القليله
الماضيه اوقاف الدول استيراد الابقار
البرازيليه ابرزها الصين وتايلاند والاردن
وايران على خلفيه اكتشاف حالتي اصابه
بالمرض في ولايه برا ايضا في مصر تم تعليق
الاستيراد من المناطق التي اعلنت فيها
الاصابات وهو ما فعلت روسيا ايضا بينما
كشفت البرازيل ان الحالات المكتشفه غير
نمطيه اي ليست من النوع الذي يشكل خطوره
على الانسان ويشكل تعليق الصادرات خطرا
كبيرا على قطاع الثروه الحيوانيه المهم في
البرازيل وهو احد اكبر هذه القطاعات في
العالم المزيد عن تفاصيل بدايات هذا المرض
مع علاء سرحان
مرض جنون البقر اكتشف لاول مره في
بريطانيا عام
1986 في عام 2001 انتشر بعدها في امريكا
وكندا وفرنسا ومن ثم الى عديد من دول
العالم على مدار السنوات تم ذبح اربعه
ملايين ونصف المليون راس ماشيه لاحتواء
انتشار المرض كما انخفض عدد حالات الاصابه
بعد فرض حظر على الاعلاف التي يعتقد انها
تسبب المرض هو مرض قاتل ربط بمرض دماغي
يعاني منه البشر يهاجم الدماغ والجهاز
العصبي ويدمر هما تدريجيا يعتقد ان
الاصابه به تنتج عن تناول اللحوم الملوثه
او المنتجات الاخرى من الماشيه المصابه
باستثناء منتجات الالبان اعراضه تكون
نفسيه وتصاحبه تغيرات سلوكيه اضافه الى
عجز في الحركه واضطرابات في الذاكره حسب
البيانات المتاحه حتى عام 2022
فان البرازيل تشكل 20% من صادرات العالم
لللحوم وكانت الصين هي السوق الرئيسيه
للحوم البرازيليه حيث تشكل حوالي 33% من
صادرات البرازيل الاجماليه تليها هونغ
كونغ ومصر والامارات وتشيلي
[موسيقى]
على كل ينضم الينا من عمان حازم الصمادي
مساعد امين عام التسويق والجوده في وزاره
الزراعه اهلا بك الاردن اذا يمنع لحوم
البرازيليه اولا مع علاقه ذلك بجنون البقر
ما مدى دقه هذه المعلومات
صباح الخير ستي زي ما بتعرفي اليوم
الامراض العابره للحدود بشكل عام ومن
ضمنها الامراض الحيوانيه تهدد حاله
الاستقرار في الامن الغذائي العالمي بشكل
عام وتؤدي الى تقلبات لا شك في الاسعار
مثل ما تفضلتي انه موضوع جنون البقر كمرض
هذا يؤثر على حاله الثروه الحيوانيه
بالدرجه الاولى وبالتالي الدول تجد خيارات
مختلفه ومتعدده للتعامل مع مثل هذا المرض
عنا في الاردن يمكن يكون الحاله بمجرد
الاعلان عنها في 26/2 اخذت الحكومه من
خلال وزاره الزراعه قرار بوقف الاستيراد
من البرازيل لحين وضوح الرؤيه والاطلاع
على الاجراءات المتخذه من السلطات
البيطريه في البرازي ولكن استاذ حازم
البعيده الماضيه نتحدث عن اصابه حوالي 80%
من ابقار الاردن الحلوب بالحمى القلاعيه
وفق نقابه البيطريين بالتالي بين الحمى
القلاعيه من جهه وجنون البقر من الجهه
الاخرى كيف ستعامل الاردن مع هذه الازمه
يعني انا بدي اشكرك على هذا الاهتمام وهذه
المتابعه دائما احنا في الاردن سياستنا
واضحه من خلال منع الامراض العابره للحدود
من الانتشار منع دخول امراض جديده الحفاظ
على الحاله
الحجريه البيطريه بصوره سليمه وبنفس الوقت
دائما نسعى لتعدد الاستيراد اليوم لدينا
ما يقارب 19 منشا الاستيراد لحوم العجل
والحيوانات الحيه بحيث انه نامن احتياجات
المواطنين في الشهر الفضيل ان شاء الله
طيب السيد حازم منذ سنوات منذ عام 93
تحديدا لم يسمع العالم بجنون البقر متفشي
هل هناك مخاوف من ان تتكرر هذه الموجه ان
هذا النمط مستبعد
هذا امر نمطي يمكن كان كمان كانت في حاله
البرازيل في ثلاث تسعه 2021 ظهرت عندهم
حاله مشابهه استمرت لفتره قصيره جدا ومن
ثم تم السيطره عليها حتى اليوم حاله جنون
البقر مثل ما تفضلتي اللي ظهرت في
البرازيل هي حاله محدوده في حالتين
مختلفات النشر عنهن على الموقع الالكتروني
للمنظمه العالميه لصحه الحيوان بعد التاكد
من من من من طبيعه المرض والتاكد من انه
بتحدث عن جنون بقر وفق الفحوصات المخبريه
استاذ حازم
هل استاذ حزم هل يؤثر وقف استيراد العجول
الى الاردن على كميات اللحوم يعني نحن
نعلم بان الاردن يستهلك كميات كبيره من
اللحم ورمضان على الابواب كمان
انا بدي اشكرك يعني هو لا شك اليوم احنا
بنتحدث على انه الكميات او الاحتياجات
رمضان في ظل ظروف الشحن الشحن من البرازيل
للاردن بيحتاج ما يقارب الخمسه واربعين
يوم وبالتالي احتياجاتنا لشهر رمضان اصبحت
موجوده لدينا في الاردن اي شحنه سيتم
شحنها بعد هذا التاريخ هي ستاتي بعد الشهر
الفضيل دائما الاردن عنا احتياج شهري في
شهر رمضان من اللحوم العجل ما يقارب
الثلاث الاف و750 طن بحمده تعالى اليوم
لدينا ما يقارب 12 الف
طن من لحوم العجل المتاحه على شكل اما
لحوم او ذبائح معده حيوانات معدله الذبح
وهذا يعني بيعطينا حاله من الاستقرار في
توافر الغذاء او في توافر اللحم العجل
بحمده تعالى بيعطينا مخزون استراتيجي لمئه
يوم قادم ان شاء الله تمام
هل يمكن ان تتحول الاردن الى لحوم
المختبرات طالما انها اكثر صحه امانا
ونظافه وبدون جنون
اللحوم المختبرات
صار في هاي التقنيات كمان ولحمه ثلاثيه
الابعاد تماما
تماما لدينا بدائل متعدده احنا دائما
بندرس الحالات المرضيه اللي بتظهر وبنضع
استراتيجيه واضحه للتعامل معها يعني عنا
اليوم اللجنه فنيه متخصصه عم تدرس الوضع
اللي موجود في العالم واللي موجود في
البرازيل بالذات لنختار البدائل المناسبه
للمرحله القادمه ولكن يمكن اللحوم العجل
من البرازيل بالنسبه للاردن لا تشكل اكثر
من 13%
كحوم مستورده احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر من
عمان حازم الصنادي مساعد امين عام تسويق
والجوده في وزاره الزراعه شكرا لك